[Musique]
et
bonjour didier lemaire bonjour vous
publiez l'être dans les sables de la
république sous titré avant qu'il ne
soit trop tard ccc chez robert laffont
vous êtes ce professeur de philosophie
de trappes qui inquiète et qui a fait la
une de l'actualité il ya un an on va en
reparler puisque vous parlez beaucoup
dans ce livre peut-être un mot sur eux
une star de la république c'est un
mouchoir sur ses péniches contient un
guide et un autre pour les instituteurs
les universitaires noir delà de la
république oui ce n'est pas un terme
militaire bien danser des instituteurs
phacélie c'était l'époque où avant avant
qu'on débaptise le ministère de
l'instruction publique en le rebaptisant
ministère de l'éducation nationale
c'était l'époque où l'école jouer encore
ce rôle très important de ciment de la
nation par l'instruction est aussi qui
permettait je pense à cette époque-là de
aux élèves
[Musique]
une certaine mobilité sociale qui
aujourd'hui vraiment perdu c'était les
défenseurs de la république et de la
laïcité en ce sens vous êtes leur
descendre oui je m'inscris dans cette
tradition la tour eiffel alors on va
parler de ce qu'on appelait la sphère le
maire fossilisés on peut appeler ça
comme ça en tout cas les débats qui ont
suivi vos prises de position et votre
dénonciation de la montée de l'islamisme
notamment rattrape mais peut-être
quelques mots sur roues puisque vous en
parlez dans le livre d'abord la philo
alors vous devez tombé dedans jeune a 13
ans en lisant camus le mythe de sisyphe
à ça j'ai découvert dans ce livre une
réflexion sur l'absurde sur l'existence
qui m'a qui m'a tout de suite parlé j'ai
trouvé un philosophe qu'il avait les
mots pour dire à la fois mon sentiment
est en même temps qu' il y avait le
courage de penser quelque chose de
difficile quelque chose qu'on préférait
mettre de côté et ce courage de camus
m'a vraiment impressionné je crois
d'ailleurs que c'est peut-être un peu le
le film dans dans ma carrière
philosophie qui est dans ma vie j'en
sais quelque chose qui vous oui dans ma
rencontre avec les philosophes les
retrouver avec schopenhauer quelques
années plus tard avec pascal aussi sa
réflexion sur la condition humaine avec
sénèque également qu' qui est un
philosophe qui nuance beaucoup et qui
est aussi peut-être quelqu'un qui
prépare à la lecture de montagne assez
bien alors c'est ça il ya ya ya kabylie
dk bus au départ il ya toutes les
lectures philosophiques et puis vont
après l'université
et en même temps on a la pression prenez
parfois d'aider des chemins de traverse
même dans les premiers enseignements
vous faites vous parlez de de cuisine
vous parlez d'ennui
c'était une façon d'intéresser les nos
élèves à la philosophie oui j'ai
toujours cherché à relier la philosophie
et le monde réel j'ai toujours cherché à
ne ne pas séparer les deux l'abstraction
pour moi elle est une manière de donner
une lumière mais pas non plus de fuir le
monde dans la spéculation et je pense
aussi que dans cette forme
d'enseignement ou renvoie sans cesse
l'élève a même à ses expériences ses
propres expériences à l'observation
on trouve plus de joie à
apprendre à philosopher quand on est
confronté justement au réel et en même
temps
mais c'est peut-être cette phase et
d'après ce que je sais pas tellement
facile parce qu'on appelle le
pédagogisme vous êtes vous êtes de ceux
qui considèrent que nous cédions il est
là pour apprendre quelque chose d'assez
élèves ben oui ça c'est ce que j'ai
appris à l'université j'ai eu quand même
de la chance d'avoir de grands maîtres
comme par exemple alexis philonenko
j'ai eu beaucoup de grands maîtres et je
me suis rendu compte que l'important
n'était pas dans la forme pédagogique
met donc vraiment dans la dans la teneur
et dans les exigences de la pensée est
finalement et c'est ça que m'ont appris
mais m et c'est aussi ce que j'ai
transmis dès les premières années où
j'ai tenté de transmettre en tout cas
mais à mes élèves et d'ailleurs c'est un
métier extraordinaire parce que quand on
y arrive tout le monde et soyeux dans la
classe les élèves se sentent
intelligents se sentent outillés pour
pour comprendre mieux le monde fasse et
c'est vraiment une joie ce métier c'est
un bonheur lassitude voire bonheur et en
vous lisant on se dit aussi c'est quand
même un sacerdoce parce que vous
racontez les premières années
d'enseignement vous êtes nommé en
normandie pendant plusieurs plusieurs
établissements alors là on vous dit oui
il faut faire la guerre je suis là parce
qu'il vient avec un flingue au cours
l'année dernière il ya un prof qui s'est
fait tabasser ou dans un autre
établissement bon ben il pleut quand il
pleut dehors il pleut 2 de france là on
se dit quand même il faut quand même une
sorte de foi très très bien nous créons
soit pour pour se dire quoi je voudrais
vous qu'au départ je ne pensais pas
rester dans l'éducation nationale parce
que le salaire était très faible les
conditions d'enseignement pas
extraordinaire et puis moi même avant
que ma pédagogie ou en tout cas que mon
rapport à l'élève soit vraiment à la
hauteur du poste dans ma fonction j'ai
mis quelques quelques années oui et puis
j'ai rencontré pas mal de difficultés
dans des établissements terrible de ce
qu'on appelait à l'époque de zones
sensibles j'ai une collègue à villeneuve
la garenne qui a été tué à la sortie du
lycée oui c'était c'était vraiment des
années des années difficiles on en voit
un jeune professeur
expérimenté dans les lycées finalement
les plus les plus dangereuses et elle
est plus les plus difficiles alors il ya
dans les années 2000 bas vous acceptez
de aux deux mesures vous fait d'être
d'être prof au lycée de trappes
et là vous sentez vite bien quoi
il dit avoir sorti vite bien vous sentez
utile oui je pense que j'ai des élèves à
trappes je venais d'un lycée plus
privilégiés à rambouillet avec des
élèves d'ailleurs de très bon niveau que
certains jeux déterminé en classes
préparatoires et là je sens que j'ai
plus du tout
des élèves de ce niveau là mais j'ai des
élèves qui ont
comme en dire beaucoup d'énergie et une
envie d'apprendre et donc j'arrive par
le dialogue avec le wave ii a très vite
à de très beaux résultats dans toutes
les classes parce qu'il ya aussi des
classes très difficile mais quand même
je sens que ça marche bien et je me sens
surtout utile d'illzach et oui c'est ça
qui fait la beauté aussi de 2,2 ce
métier c'est gratifiant évidemment c'est
gratifiant de voir ses propres résultats
si on est à lui le grand bon en fait un
très bon prof mais mais c'est vrai qu'on
a des mandats des élèves qui sont déjà
presque sur une route va tout va tout
est absolument
et et vous avez senti alors là on est
dans les années 2000 et puis vous allez
rester une vingtaine 20 ans
enfin frappe vous avez senti une
évolution sociologique de composition de
vos de vos classes notamment oui
alors le soleil moi je suis pas
sociologue de statistiques je n'ai pas
de chiffres mais ce que j'ai vu c'est
que il y avait par exemple dans les
années 2000 il y avait plus d'enfants
d'origine portugaise ou de familles
portugaises mais les portugais né en
france j'en ai eu beaucoup moins à
partir de
2015 alors il en reste un il ya encore
des portugais attrape mais il y en à moi
c'est lui voilà ce que j'ai surtout
constaté
c'est une une absence de mixité sociale
au départ on avait quand même on avait
quand même des lycéens qui venait des
villes alentour donc qu'ils avaient un
niveau social plus élevé 4 ap qui est
quand même je le rappelle une des villes
les plus pauvres des yvelines et
[Musique]
cette mixité
permettait je pense aussi plus de
facilité dans l'enseignement parce que
quand on n'a pas de mixité sociale on se
retrouve face à des groupes qui ont des
comportements plus stéréotypé
des manières de parler aussi plus
stéréotypé et l'hétérogénéité c'est
toujours quelque chose qui nous permet
d'aller vers l'universel
alors il ya une date qui est important
c'est 2015 c'est 2015 l année d'aider
des attentats de charlie d'hyper cacher
du bataclan de policiers qui sont qui
sont tués
c'est à ce moment là que vous apercevez
que les choses sont en train de changer
un oui à des signes auparavant de deux
attentats des tours de new york il ya
déjà des signes quelques élèves mais
c'est vraiment très très localisé à
partir de 2015 je me retrouve face à des
classes qui dans l'ensemble pour
certaines
renvoie dos à dos les terroristes
islamistes les tueurs et les victimes
et plus grave après le bataclan
dans une classe je sens un très grand
malaise et des élèves qui veulent éviter
le sujet est une élève en particulier
qui qui était ma meilleure élève depuis
le début de l'année qui va suite à une
prise de parole sur cette question là
dans ma classe
va cesser de faire de la philosophie et
va cesser même de me regarder de me
répondre jusqu'à la fin de l'année ce
film oui là il ya quelque chose qui se
passe quoi il ya aussi déjà des premiers
départs pour le diable oui mais ça alors
ça je n'en ai pas
je le découvre dans mon année avec
raphaëlle bacqué ariane chemin et qui
écrivent d'autun voilà un peu plus tard
en 2018 puisqu'elles vont mener une
enquête à trappes pendant un an je vais
les accompagner
elles vont venir me voir régulièrement
je vais leur proposer mes élèves de
rencontrer mes élèves etc et c'est en
fait un peu plus tard en 2015 2016 je
comprends qu'il se passe quelque chose
d'anormal mais je je n'ai je prends
conscience je commence à prendre
conscience de mon ignorance c'est mon
moment quelque sorte socratique mais je
ne vais en sortir qu un peu plus tard à
partir de 2017 alors n'y est quand même
des efforts qui sont faits il ya
notamment des pièces qu'elle goudou
qu'elle vous amenez vos élèves comme
d'illiad comme les désaxés il ya des
films aussi il vous dit allah vous dites
d'ailleurs c'est à la fois beaucoup et
très peu ce genre de jeu alors de façon
générale je pense que l'art est quelque
chose de central dans la construction
dans la formation parce que dans les
autres disciplines on a affaire à des
choses abstraites et général dans là on
a affaire à la singularité humaine dans
la littérature notamment et cette
singularité justement la force de l'art
c'est de nous là de pouvoir l'a
communiqué donc il me semble que face à
une idéologie qui réduit l'individu à
une appartenance un groupe l'art est un
très très bon moyen de surmonter des
résistances
intellectuelle
d'une part d'autre part c'était aussi un
moyen pour moi de donner la parole aux
élèves de leur permettre de s'exprimer
sur une situation qui pour eux
très douloureuse et difficile très
difficile parce que j'espérais parce que
d'un côté ils sont pris par leur
communauté et une pression idéologique
forte et de l'autre à l'école ils font
une expérience de la liberté qui leur
claire d'aller dans la plupart du temps
et dans laquelle ils s'épanouissent et
comment concilier les deux comment
concilier les deux je crois que tu es là
les trajectoires de télé individuel que
racontent ces pièces ou ses films ça me
permet peut-être de parler quoi par
l'identification
notamment et oui j'ai vu que ça avait un
certain effet et je dis incertain pour
ce qu' il faudrait que les élèves
aillent davantage au théâtre pour que
cette expérience est vraiment des effets
construc constructif et ceux qui liront
le livre le verrou d'ailleurs vous
facilite pas forcément la tâche pour
pouvoir
accueillir des pièces etc mais
d'ailleurs vous parler du livre de
raphaëlle bacqué d'ariane chemin la
communauté le desert rap
là est ce qu'avec ce se livrer enfin ce
qu'ils racontent vous avez vous touchez
du doigt qu'il ya une sorte de déni quoi
il parle le livre est très mal
accueillie en relais cas ici à devoir à
tout et derrière il ya pas de signatures
à travers parce que signature c'est pas
possible la librairie qui peut nous
valoir dans les trappes de pagayer un
livre comme ça yann signature à 50
indique une passe pas on se passe très
mal vient d'ailleurs j'essaye suite à
cet échec j'essaie d'organiser une
nouvelle une nouvelle présentation et la
musique avec des chercheurs hugo michon
accepte de participer c'est quand même
pas rien je contacte même pascal
blanchard pour avoir une opposition et
donc les deux journalistes et là c'est
impossible c'est à dire que altra ville
a craqué dans les alentours aucune ville
je vais donc voir aussi la députée de la
république en marche pour lui demander
son soutien nadia et qui est devenue
miss de la ville après absolument elle
me dit qu'elle va faire son possible et
puis un mois plus tard elle m'explique
que ses amis de la reine ne souhaite pas
nous accueillir donc on sent oui un déni
et paix de très très fortes résistances
politiques
à ce sujet a validé ce sujet et quand on
est trop de 6,12 de dire quand on
enseigne l'art de doute et vous font de
de séparer le savoir de la croyance
comment on réagit face justement à se
saisit des mots doux du complot 10 ou de
croyances qui deviennent de plus en plus
présente ses élèves alors direct la
difficulté s'est bien séparé le travail
de formation philosophique
qui doit avoir un cadre je pense wicked
de l'intérieur du lycée en classes de la
ville neutre et est vraiment séparé là
pour le coup de tout et puis
ponctuellement des actions prévention
qui ont été menées avec la préfecture
des yvelines je pense que je peux me
vanter certainement d'être le professeur
dans l'académie qui a eu sans doute le
plus de subventions pour organiser des
actions prévention mais qui n'étaient
pas directement mené par moi même c'est
à dire elle était accompagnée par par
des sociologues par
des pièces de théâtre justement qui ont
eu lieu aussi dans la classe celui
théâtre forum par exemple
et vous interrogez de plus en plus sauf
au oui bien sûr cette notion la
tolérance qu'est ce que ça veut dire par
rapport à des gens qui qui se considère
comme étant nos ennemis et c'est dans
cette atmosphère là qu'arrive
l'assassinât fallout et la décapitation
de sympathie qui est votre première
réaction d'ailleurs cède on a
l'impression à une réaction de silence
de sidération de repli sur compte sur
vous même oui pendant quelques jours oui
puisque vous ce qu'est ce qui se conçoit
que nous avons été nombreux à
avoir cette réaction là et puis je sens
monter en moi une forme de colère et
cette colère je fais l'exprimer dans un
texte où j'écris et que j'adresse aux
enseignants et qui sera publié dans
l'ope cent au début du mois de novembre
juste à la rentrée et c'est à ce moment
là que je peux dire que ma vie bascule
puisqu'à ce moment là
la police décide ce n'est pas
l'éducation nationale d'ailleurs je
pense mais c'est la police qui décide de
me mettre sous escorte c'est à dire que
mes entrées et les sorties du lycée sont
accompagnés par des policiers du site
juste une phrase à de cette tribune vous
dites dans cette vue nous sommes au
début d'une guerre par la terreur qui va
se généraliser son plaisir
c'est votre correction alors quelle
quelle a été la réaction de vos
collègues et de vos élèves justement
après cette lettre qui s'adresse d'abord
à la vie alors ça je leur explique
normes ont expliqué dans mon livre vous
n'allez pas très envie de discuter de ça
avec vous élève pour la raison que vous
expliquez d'ailleurs tout à l'aise dès
qu'il le court c'est une chose
le leurs réflexions sur la société c'est
toutes choses oui absolument et le cadre
doit rester le cas parce que sinon je
mon travail n'a plus de sens et puis de
toute façon c'est une obligation
professionnelle mais que j'approuve
absolument donc je ne fais pas de
politique en place simplement les élèves
à la rentrée vont découvrir cette lettre
certains surveillants d'ailleurs dans le
lycée vont accusé d'islamophobie ou de
racisme donc je crois qu'il ya aussi une
relation entre le milieu de trappes et
la parole des élèves sans doute les
parents ou ailleurs et puis je me
retrouve notre secours de retrouver le
petit directement cellule c'est
exactement la même chose
bon moi j'ai quand même une chance c'est
que j'ai enseigné 20 ans à trappes je
crois que j'ai une très bonne réputation
auprès des parents parce que je me suis
beaucoup investi et que de nombreux
élèves on peut le dire on quand même le
baccalauréat vos collègues le soutien
des guerriers des trains de nuit donc je
peux pas passer pour un raciste ça
marche pas avec moi
ça ne peut pas passer
mais cela dit la réaction des élèves
c'est l'incompréhension la colère et
puis déjà des accusations donc il va
falloir recadrer un petit peu les choses
avec eux on vous dit l'élève qui vous
dit oui pourquoi vous avez écrit un
article contre nous contre ne s'est pas
du tout pour la voir alors bon je ne
vais pas lancer ses anciens c'est la
manipulation qui commence à la
manipulation qui commence et c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs la situation est
périlleuse elle est terrible parce que
si si les gens dans la vie dans cette
première on peut dire pépinière
djihadistes d'europe pense que le
professeur de philosophie de la ville
est
écrit ce des textes contre les enfants
de cette ville
qu'est ce que va-t-il se passer ensuite
voir la vue de ce petit la force de la
leur beurre et de voilà c'est courir aux
hawks et en vidant ses dribbles et vous
à ce moment là qu'est ce que c'est quoi
votre il ya évidemment la peur je
suppose non pas trop regardé comme un
bon je dois ne s'est pas la peur ça
c'est enfin je suis prudent je suis
extrêmement prudent je mets quelques
jours à comprendre et à intégrer le fait
que je peux être attaqué on dit aux
jeunes eux pour y être le deuxième sujet
contre ça s'est un peu plus tard je me
serais je le saurai au mois de janvier
qu'une qu'une personne qui connaît très
bien la ville qui a vécu longtemps avec
lesquels d'ailleurs j'ai eu deux
relations dans le cadre d'une
association trappe
dit à une journaliste que si je continue
de parler de l'islamisme et de trappes
je saurai le prochain samuel petit donc
c'est un avertissement ce n'est pas une
menace de satin
mais c'est clair voilà c'est bon donc
moi au mois de novembre je comprends je
mets quelques jours à comprendre que je
peux me faire tuer demain je l'assumé et
je prends le risque de continuer à
parler je vraiment je jeu l'assument
voilà donc je ne vis pas dans la peur
ensuite viendra peur de nous non mais
vous va bon et en même temps à gaza il
ya les bleus basse il ya la tentative de
vous décrédibilisez aussi alors ça c'est
le plus tard mitu de la république c'est
un peu plus facile qu'au mois de février
ça ça joue quand même alors la balle
assez la grande campagne de de l'ancien
maire de trappes qui est nouveau c'est
qu'il se sent très bien
[Musique]
devenir très mais je les ai vus tout de
suite vu que j'ai vu tout de suite j'ai
compris tout de suite qui lui qui
n'utilisaient puisque je savais que que
son élection elle être validé
donc
il m'a utilisé pouce pour victimiser
la ville de traves est limpide donc
apparaître comme le défenseur le
chevalier blanc et donc il a très bien
réussi bien bien entendu
aussi je pense que c'est le signe que ce
que j'ai dit n'est pas faux c'est à dire
que cette ville est conquise par par les
islamistes aujourd'hui par pas cette
pression identitaire qui s'exerce à la
fois dans les commerces les tenues
vestimentaires
les moeurs les moeurs les jeunes filles
d'origine maghrébine ou de parents
maghrébins ne vont pas dans les cafés la
trappe c'est pas plus si pour elle une
femme qui viendrait d'ailleurs elle peut
y rentrer et je leur en ai fait
l'expérience mais voilà cc n'y a pas
d'interdiction mais jamais jamais les
moeurs sont là
quand on va sur le marché on le voit
aussi qui est servi en premier par les
commerçants
est en réalité c'est toujours pareil
c'est à dire que c'est pas c'est pas le
c'est pal alerte qu'on considère ces
lanceurs d alerte qu'on essaye de
décrédibiliser oui et je dois dire que
des soustrait enfin des points très
semblable à la faire ça veut le pâtis 1
par chance
oui je t'avais dit comme ça mais c'est
vrai c'est ça aussi mais ce qui est
grave c'est qu'une partie de la presse
et jouer à ce jeu trouble pour pour
faire du buzz je pense
aussi par conviction idéologique de
certains journalistes
d'ailleurs c'était très intéressant
parce qu'au mois de novembre ou au mois
de décembre fin novembre j'ai un
journaliste de radio canada qui vient me
voir qui fait un reportage attrapé il
montre le reportage qu'il a fait une
semaine plus tôt à montpellier et en
étudiant trappe en faisant un vrai
travail d'investigation attrape il
interrogé mais la vie s'est promené dans
la ville met à l'interroger longuement
il m'a dit j'ai changé point de vue je
je je je pensais que la laïcité c'était
contre les musulmans je souscrive est de
donner à ce discours là que la france
exagérait instrumentalisé
de les lois et il a changé de point de
vue moi j'ai pas vu beaucoup de
journalistes faire un travail d'enquêté
d'investigation dans la presse écrite où
nous vivons voilà c'est tj commentaires
d'autres commentaires et au même moment
les faits et oui ça m'a beaucoup
attristé sur l'état quand de notre pays
et du bois
évidemment donc vous avez été obligé
d'abandonner votre rejet du mois à
trappes pour vous là il ya des choses le
l'éducation nationale à l'humour parce
qu'on doive pour vous et par exemple
argenteuil d'argenteuil ces trappes même
chose oui alors nous sommes au mois
d'avril et au mois d'avril alors qu'on a
on a on m'a poussé à changer de statut
je vais pas rentrer dans le détail en me
disant on va être très bienveillant avec
vous on envoie un ordre de mission
j'ai deux jours pour rejoindre le lycée
d'argenteuil je suis sous protection
policière ça veut dire que j'ai une
voiture et les officiers de sécurité qui
m'accompagne partout où je vais alors
donc je pose la question
l'administration vous imaginez que je
vais aller avec mes officiers de
sécurité jusqu'où dans ma salle de
classe donc mon avocate
à ce moment là fait jouer le droit de
retrait et
je refuse évidemment ce taux ce qui
aurait mis en danger d'abord ma vie mais
peut-être aussi celle de mes collègues
et puis la sérénité même de la ville
c'est c'est tout à fait fantastique et
ça montre dans l'absurde dans l'absurde
absolument je ne sais pas s'il ya eu des
intentions mais je doute fort que le
ministre n'ait pas été informé de cette
décision donc donc je me demande qu'elle
était de quelques le calcul qu'il y
avait derrière un dernier vous parce
qu'il veut leur malheureusement arrivent
à la fin de saison tient vous dites il
nous faut nous retrouver nous mêmes
c'est dans le dernier chapitre de ce
livre il nous reste peu tôt pour
réfléchir à notre avenir
vous êtes pessimiste sur notre capacité
à je suis pessimiste sur le constat
après je suis je suis toujours je suis
une place toujours dans la perspective
d'une action et je crois que cette
action il est encore temps de la mener
il est encore temps de prendre
conscience de sortir du déni et je crois
qu'une partie des français d'ailleurs le
souhaitent et ont déjà fait des parents
sous sens ça va être aux politiques
aujourd'hui de répondre à cette attente
la et d'y répondre de façon républicaine
mais d'une façon forte il faut restaurer
la république partout il faut refonder
je pense l'école qui est vraiment très
très mal en point mais également aussi
la police qui n'est plus respectée
partout sur le territoire et peut-être
aussi comprendre que la justice doit
prendre en compte une situation qui est
proche d'un état de guerre et qui fait
que les le droit habituel ne peut pas
s'appliquer quand on pense je vais
donner un exemple tout de suite que des
parents fichier est ce qu'ils ont déjà
été condamnés pour des actes de violence
qui ont menacé un enseignant de mort
prennent aujourd'hui six mois de prison
avec sursis c'est comme un permis de
recommencer donc il ya un problème il ya
un problème très grave je crois qu'il
est vraiment temps aujourd'hui pour que
les politiques le prennent en rencontres
et c'était aussi le sens de ceux de ce
livre c'est à la fois un témoignage avec
ponctuée de moments de réflexion plus
philosophique mais qui sont emportés la
touche j'en vois au lit parce qu'il
c'est vrai que les réseaux sur la
laïcité sur l'islam isme sur le terreau
semis sur le risque et c'est donc il ya
pas mal de ponctuation de réflexion et
puis à la fin oui il ya je me tourne
toujours vers le réel et vers l'action
et notre responsabilité à tous deux
citoyens parce que je n'y a pas de
fatalité l'islamisme c'est pas un
phénomène fatale c'est pas c'est celle
ci dépend de nous de l'arrêter
merci beaucoup d'idées le maître
j'envoie donc à votre livre lettres dans
les serres de la république c'est chez
robert laffont merci merci
[Musique]